1) Idea Every Day
Scott Myers, DePaul University Professor/Screenwriter/Creator
Gointothestory.blcklst(dot)com: First of all
let’s just image that we have ten track
of our brain, that our brain can do ten things
at once, one of those tracks as a writer should
be sensitive or aware of ideas.
They are out there, they are out there all
of the time all over the place.
They are in newspaper articles, they are in
conversations you hear with people in a coffee
shop, they are on the radio.
They are on click, your click, click, click,
thing that happens.
For example I know David Rabinowitz and Charlie
Wachtel who wrote BlacKkKlansman I interview
them and I said how did you guys come up with
it and I think David said well I was trying
to avoid writing and so I was doing the click
thing and I stumbled on this Facebook article
about this guy Ron Stallworth the first black
policeman in Colorado Springs who did this
thing with The Klan so that is how they discovered
it.
The one thing is just be conscience of it.
The other thing is be intentional like everyday
you should be thinking about story ideas.
It’s going to vary from person to person
but there have been times in my life where
I have literally said I am going to come up
with an idea today, every day.
And a third point to that related is Dr. Linus
Pauling who is the only person to win two
Nobel prizes and he has that saying the best
way to come up with good idea is to come up
with a lot of ideas and so that’s a third
point that you can do is write a lot of ideas.
Keep a file like I’ve got a Word file stretching
back 20 some odd years with literally hundred
and hundreds of ideas some of them awful but
you keep working that muscle and then eventually
I think chances are you’re going to surface
something.
Now then you have to assess the ideas.
There are certain questions you can ask like
is this big enough to be a movie, who is the
audience for this, what is the hook, that
central conceit.
Like when I sold K-9 I remember going into
an executives office and they said what you
guys did was so brilliant.
You took the buddy action comedy formula (the
police cop) and you put in Rin Tin Tin who
was like the biggest star in Hollywood in
the 1920’s.
I learned a very valuable lesson there which
is you always when someone gives you a compliment
even if you didn’t mean it you go yes, that’s
exactly what I mean.
I said yes, that’s exactly what I thinking
because I hadn’t thought that at all.
But at that point in time in 1980 I could
walk into any producer’s office, any bar
where people where hanging out what are you
working on?
Yeah, I got this idea K-9, loner cop, new
partner, police dog.
They would see that.
The hook there is the police dog, nobody had
done that.
INCEPTION, being able to go inside someone’s….GROUNDHOG
DAY…that thing…what’s that thing that
is going to get it off from something else?
So those are some key…have one part of your
brain going, be intentional about it, be generating
a lot of ideas and hope that you will come
up with some really good ones (some strong
ones) and then assess them to make sure that
you feel that it’s big enough and good enough
to be a movie.
2) The 100 Idea Theory
William C. Martell, Author/Screenwriter: My
first step in writing a screenplay is coming
up basically with 100 ideas and picking the
best idea.
I have a thing called the 100 Idea Theory,
it doesn’t have to be 100 ideas but if I
come up with 1 idea, that’s 1 idea (it could
be a terrible idea) but if I come up with
100 ideas or 60 ideas or whatever I can comb
through and find the very best idea and then
I take it to Thunderdome.
I take that idea and go if I write the script
everyone is going to pick it apart.
I’m going to pick it apart first.
I want to find all the flaws with whatever
the idea is and get past those flaws and remove
them so that the ideas is great
3) Twenty Ways
Karl Iglesias, Author/Screenwriter: That is
actually the bane of a writer’s existence,
especially a screenwriter, to come up with
something new.
When you think about, I think in the second
edition of 101 Habits: Insider’s Secrets
from Hollywood’s Top Writers, Bill Marsilii
one of the screenwriters there, talks about
doing the 20’s.
So for him anything that he thinks about,
any event, any scene, character whatever,
he thinks of kind of listing 20 different
ways of doing it.
He talks about the meet-cute in romantic comedy,
he talks about how people meet in a cute way.
Well he’s going to do 20 different thoughts
about it.
“Okay it could be this, it could be this…”
He does 20 because the first two or three
or five of them will be clichés.
They will be things that you’re automatically
going to think about because they’re the
most famous ones that we’ve seen a hundred
times.
But going deeper (and he forces himself to
go deeper) that is where you get the creativity
and originality.
And eventually when you reach past the 10
to 12 or 15 all the way up to 20, you’ll
start getting really original ways because
you force yourself.
And so that is what the writer needs to do.
Force yourself to go deeper in order to create
some original writing.
Do the 20 for just anything.
It could be 20 different ways to rob a bank.
20 different ways to say I love you.
20 different ways to break up with someone.
20 different ways to kill someone.
There are all these different things that
you’ve seen a 100 times and when you see
it over and over again you go “Hmm…”
because you’ve seen it a 100 times and it’s
only the movies that break out…stories that
break out are the ones that are truly original,
right?
4) What’s The Big Problem?
Erik Bork, Author/Screenwriter: To me where
it starts is a really compelling problem that
is going to take the whole story to be solved.
That millions of strangers consuming that
story would be able to identify with this
problem and care that it gets solved and be
really entertained by the process of watching
people trying to solve it.
So that’s kind of a lot of things in one
but to me that’s kind of where it all starts
with.
There is something that someone is going through
in life that really matters to them and hopefully
to us as the audience.
It’s really important, it’s really difficult.
It’s going to take a lot of effort and active
action toward trying to solve it which isn’t
going to work.
So it’s difficult, it’s complicated, trying
to solve it usually leads to pushback and
complications and things that don’t go as
planned and so that tends to build that sense
of problematic situations so it’s growing
and escalating, building over the course of
the story and then in the end there is some
kind of resolution that has taken the audience
on a journey and usually taken certain characters
on a journey where they’re not the same
as what they were and therefore it was meaningful
and important in some way that they went through
that.
5) True Life Stories
Stanley M. Brooks, Producer/Director/Screenwriter:
There is certainly the wow factor of that
is the most amazing thing I’ve ever heard.
I have to have that.
I have to have that right now.
How do I get that story, that book or magazine
or true life story.
When I heard the story of Christine Pelisek
a fact-checker at 23-years-old and working
at LA Weekly and breaking the Grim Sleeper
serial killer in Los Angeles I didn’t need
to know anymore.
But then there are stories that I just can’t
let go of and I will go back to and go back
to and those are the ones hopefully the next
movie I’m going to make in the Amazon was
a story that I chased for five years, it’s
a true life story and I just couldn’t let
it go.
Some other producer got it and failed at developing
it.
I would call every 6 months and after about
a year and a half they abandoned the other
producer and went with me and I just could
not let it go.
It was a story I had to tell one way or another
I was going to tell that story, that is the
true story of Juliane Koepcke who in 1972
was living in Peru going to The American School.
She was 18 and in her senior year.
Her parents were noted Zoologists.
She spent part of her childhood in the Amazon.
Her parents were cataloging butterflies and
bats and then when she got to middle school
they moved her to Lima and she spoke perfect
German, perfect English, perfect Spanish.
Because they are on a different schedule than
us because there seasons are different than
us the school year ends in December.
So she was both graduating and going to her
prom in December and her dad wanted them to
go to the Amazon on Christmas Eve and she
wanted to stay and so he went early and she
and her mom stayed behind in Lima and she
went to her prom and graduated with her friends
and then they got on a plane and when the
plane was over the Amazon it got hit by lightening
twice and it disintegrated in mid air and
she was in the window seat strapped in and
as she said I didn’t leave the plane, the
plane left me and she found herself 15,000
feet in her chair upside down pinwheeling
and she blacked out, fell, hit the canopy
of the Amazon which broke her fall (it’s
a miracle).
She is the longest fall without a parachute,
and the canopy broke her fall and she landed
in the Amazon, woke up, had nothing but a
broken collar bone that she knew of.
She had one shoe, lost her glasses and for
the next 9 days followed the river and the
lessons that she learned from her father and
her own desire not to perish and was rescued.
She is a friend of mine now (she is now in
her 50’s), she’s an extraordinary woman,
she spends half of the year in Munich and
the other half in the Amazon trying to save
the rainforest.
And we are going to go down to Bogota and
the Amazon and hopefully tell that story some
time next year.
6) What If?
Brian Avenet-Bradley, Filmmaker: I think for
me a movie really begins with an idea or the
key story element or the what if.
Some times Lo [filmmaking partner Laurence
Avenet-Bradley] will have an idea or a dream
and say This is really great.
And I always jot it down, her dream and ideas
and my dreams, when I have an idea or thought
I wake up from or if I am daydreaming.
I try to write all of those little thoughts
down and then eventually what I find happens
is some of those that get written down there
is one that kind of keeps chirping, keeps
like Hey!
More ideas come to it and at a certain point
it reaches critical mass.
Usually when I have 10 or 12 pages of ideas
relating to a particular story it kind of
reaches the critical mass where I start going
okay now I’m going to figure out what this
is as a real script.
All of these ideas are great and then figuring
how it all coalesces into the script.
And then it kind of evolves like I work with
Lo when I finish a first draft because she
usually gets fresh eyes on it at that point.
So it’s great to get a fresh perspective
and then the story grows and of course as
you are inspired by locations or real things
you experience and oftentimes as it progresses
like when you start casting an actor can be
a huge influence in terms of like oh this
person changes that character.
This could make the movie turn into this.
So all of those things and it just kind of
grows so it’s fun.
It’s probably my favorite part.
7) Movie scenes and dialogue
Ryan Harris, Filmmaker: A lot of them just
stem from stories that I would love to see
as a filmmaker, that I would love to go to
the movies and watch and a lot of it comes
from movies that I’ve watched over and over
and over again or a lot of the inspiration
comes from movies in general.
You watch a scene and you think to yourself
that would be really interesting to…even
a line of dialogue that the character could
say you take that and you go that in and of
itself could be a story.
That is something that would be interesting
to explore so we just try to find things that
we would love to see as filmmakers and writers
and stories that we would love to be told.
There is actually a really interesting old
Canadian movie.
I say old, the late 90’s at it was called
When Good Ghouls Go Bad and it stars Christopher
Lloyd who is one of the most amazing actors.
Everybody knows him as Doc Brown in BACK TO
THE FUTURE but a lot of his stuff is serious
work and his comedic work is just fantastic.
So he has a line where he is speaking to his
son and his son basically says you know you
used to be this go-getter and the town is
dealing with passing of this person who got
stuck in this kiln overnight and the town
sort of deals with that heavy weight and the
dad basically says you know you used to be
happy, you used to be a go-getter, you used
to build things and make things and help people
and Christoper Lloyd says yeah and I built
the kiln that that person died in.
It’s one of those moments in that movie
where he didn’t need to say that, that didn’t
need to be a part of the movie, but it was
and that right there you go man that in and
of itself dealing with the trauma of doing
something you love and then that thing you
love hurts somebody, that in and of itself
could be an incredible story.
There are a lot of things in movies and I
try my best to write them down when I feel
them and see them and I hear them but that
would definitely be an example of something
that has inspired me.
8) The Comp Game
Travis Seppala, Author/Screenwriter: You want
to come up with an idea for a story but you
don’t know really where to start.
One good place to start
that I
have
in my book is the
comp game.
For those
of
you
who don’t know what
a
comp
is ‘This-meets-that.’
A movie like HARRY-MEETS-SALLY-meets-AIRBUD.
What is
that movie going to be?
So there is your assignment.
You come up
with